camera phone Battle Royale the goal is
you snipe somebody with the photos you
send it to the group text and they're
eliminated it's perfect look at framing
dude we've been coming to the same party
for eight years now and in no way is
that depressing
[Music]
I'm looking for that a in the sky that
you're a
[Music]
probably know a little bit late we still
have a few minutes the problem is we
don't know exactly where apertures booth
is so we have to find it before we
go on stage I'm just excited to play
another battle royale game
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
it's actually for a convention of this
size it's actually really organized but
for practical purposes it's entirely
unorganized right now I've been walking
around for the last 10 minutes just
looking for a booth and I have no idea
where it is there's there it is
I found it we walked by it yeah there's
a big game
[Music]
hug no no I'm getting camera first
that'll give Carmichael aha and selfie
[Music]
[Music]
can you uploading it doesn't matter if
it's good or bad or whatever you just
gotta continue making something the
greatest of all time about the internet
as you don't have any impact ecosystem
will be interesting actually air attacks
but this is if the characters and so why
don't we just do something that's about
interesting narratives hey guys we're
here at the vh booth at NAB 2019 camera
phone battle royale really really cool
to do it in this environment with all
these people what do you mean is it's
really cool to do it in an inappropriate
environment players take up positions
little time playing picture war plan
yeah let's go you're gonna hide what
should I go oh wait I'm gonna get other
naked shot guys it's gonna be teams of
two Nico and Nick me and Clint's Savin
red with Christian as the DM the goal is
you snipe somebody with the photos you
send it to the group text and they're
eliminated you're eliminated in the
order that text arrives if you quick
drill somebody you both take a picture
each other whoever gets the picture in
the group text thread first on
Christians phone it's like hell guys
while we're playing this game I wanted
to tell you that this video is brought
to you by Squarespace if you don't know
Squarespace is the easiest and most
effective way to get a website going for
yourself or for your business they have
an all-in-one platform with beautiful
24/7 award-winning customer service and
beautiful award-winning templates you
should really get it it's really great
they also have really awesome marketing
tools with over 30 templates so you can
let your customers know when you're
announcing a product or when you're
innovating or when you're doing
something cool
they also have a unique domain
experience that's really easy to set up
in fact do you have your own existing
URL you can transfer it to Squarespace
no problem guys has never been easier to
start an online store or sell products
online just use Squarespace go to
Squarespace complex corridor crew to get
10% off your first purchase at
squarespace.com slash corridor crew we
gotta hold our title and then of course
the grand champion of pup G winning the
big official world tournament at any gig
me I'm okay at it I'm going to use the
camera app in the threat itself the
unpredictable nature of those all this
and there's a lot of fans here at NAB so
at any moment somebody could come along
and ask you take a picture of them
and give you were exposed
we should probably stick in the corner
for now though is
which one why not we can just hide in
the aperture booth I can't be there like
um in the roses they have to get our
face right on camera yeah are we allowed
to be here I don't mean hey they said
aperture booth was the end I like how
the truth there's not a lot of angles
they can get us down here yeah and I'm
just like Maya you're just standing in
the open I gotta get down I know I know
you seem
confirmed kill
perfect look at framing dude I feel like
we're kind of cowards I mean we're kind
of being totally cowardly right now
[Music]
clear clear dude I got a fine Christian
for everybody
like
hello the timpani
you're probably paying attention to the
better whale game huh this is a
naturally I'm kind of masked in just in
this general area
Ren to be anyway
so we have with the move with the big
moves okay
[Music]
[Music]
know what happens do I lost you guys
animos up there oh look at those guys
yeah that's neat going Nick you want to
just like to hunt
they're here see if they're right around
there Ritter under breath do do you want
to just like hum Kayla you want Stevie
here
follow the following small table sorry
to be really really low
Jim
this way they went this way let's get me
[Music]
guys
[Music]
hey how's it going man Nick I'm fine
thanks our sanity so far it's been great
it's good sounds good yeah you guys
thank you position we're doing a battle
royale gamer okay and it's all about how
shoot there's Nico I got Nico I got Nico
I got Nico where'd they go
Oh Nico got Clint got Nico
wait-wait-wait-wait clinks could sit
over somewhere over here because he took
a photo of Nico from that angle he goes
down
I almost got Nick with my photo so
several pictures of making but none of
them were like good shots hey what's up
they could be around any corner here
thanks Sam Sam is probably coming
through this way you know at any second
we might run into them
that's the greater
[Music]
[Music]
so I got Clint I don't know if that came
in first or not on my screen it shows
that I got that first oh man
okay I got secrecy hey I'm just talking
to fans can be deadly
Jake almost dummy do you bleep literally
grabbed me I took a great photo but his
phone was in front of his face I'm down
I'm down
Oh Ren's down what oh that's BS
there they won't a cleans down oh yeah
No
it's in what do you wanna go this wanna
keep going around this way
Oh No Oh
yeah I'm dead yeah need go to set this
I'm gonna get ya I'm dead you're dead
oh dude where did you go I had to film
cleanse and then we ran into we ran into
Nick and Nico everyone guys are going
down that's right dude since down oh god
Nick nailed me
[Music]
we should
it's over it's over yeah Oh No who won
what is it call this is when clean guide
me out then Flint sit-down in judges
account know that Nikko got back in yeah
I let my guard down so Jake definitely
got you guys and is in fact down Jake
take the part at the end when everyone's
dying it was complete chaos because you
don't know if you're alive or you're a
dead man walking because it doesn't
matter what order the photos are coming
in on your phone it's all about Chris
headstones so you're just waiting for
the responses and that was my mistake is
that like I had I dropped my guard like
I took a photo I was like gotcha now
just chillin people are taking photos me
I'm like don't worry about it
then my photo came in second on
Kristen's phone I was like that was a
very very fun game to play in
inappropriate location yes everyone
looks at it that you really weird the
other body starts dropping I just
holding on hoping that I was maybe
somehow still alive I keep hoping and so
for the people that might think you were
dead you know
person aside at the end that Nick and I
were the most honorable winners
they want technically you never
technically you never take that really
won the game in all battle royale games
nick is truly the champion I didn't even
try you just got it in you uploading it
doesn't matter if it's good or bad or
whatever you just gotta continue making
something the greatest of all time both
on the internet film and TV you don't
have any impact ecosystem will be
interesting the actual inherent
attraction of this is if the characters
and why don't we just do something
that's about interesting characters what
we need that just people